hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
maybe you're at a point where you've
decided that you want to become a
software engineer for your career if
that's the case there's often these like
three big main paths for how to get your
first job and learning to code
professionally you can one go back to
school or university get a degree in
like computer science or software
engineering or something related two you
can go to a coding bootcamp where you'll
learn a lot of things in a short amount
of time with a community of people and
just like really hit the ground running
or three and this is like a totally
normal and plausible thing that a lot of
software engineers have done is that you
can teach yourself how to code
personally i think that self-taught
developers are some of the brightest
smartest nicest and most talented and
hardworking people i've ever had the
pleasure of working with and it only
makes sense because someone with like
the
self-motivation and the fortitude to
teach themselves an entirely new skill
like an entire new language even is
gonna have a great work ethic and coming
from a non-traditional background means
that you also bring a lot of unique
perspectives to the table too maybe
you're a retired marine or you used to
be a teacher or maybe you studied
criminal justice in college you'd be
surprised how many intangible
cross-functional skills those
backgrounds bring to the table that
being said as you might know i went
about my software engineering career a
little bit more traditionally and i went
to a four-year university and studied
computer science so
i'm actually not like the best person to
answer what it takes to become a
self-taught developer but i wanted to
learn more about how actual real
self-taught developers went about their
journeys how do they get to where they
are today what trials and tribulations
do they face are they glad they taught
themselves how to code so as you do in
the 21st century i sent out a tweet i
was lucky enough to get a bunch of
responses and interviewed a bunch of
these folks to find out and i gotta say
i was really lucky to be able to collect
such fascinating stories from a diverse
set of people they have such cool
experiences in backgrounds like
bioscience and criminology and music and
finance and i even got to talk to some
military veterans who used to serve in
the air force and the army and the navy
so the first thing that i wanted to
clear up with this group and perhaps it
was like the most burning question of
them all was
is being a self-taught developer a
legitimate career path and spoiler alert
absolutely yes
being self-taught definitely means that
you're going against the grain a little
bit because there's like this
preconceived bias or notion that like
the traditional way is like the only
right way to get into tech and i imagine
it would be really easy to not feel like
you're a legitimate or a real developer
because you didn't go to school for it
but this is just another classic case of
imposter syndrome i have a lot to say on
this topic and i've made a video before
about imposter syndrome that you can
check out right here but we'll get to
that later with regards to self-taught
developers so if you're thinking about
becoming a self-tap developer or
engineer then the first step is to
really think about whether this path is
for you and it all depends on your
priorities and your goals but especially
on your situations about money and time
at this current point in your life boot
camps in schools both cost like huge
amounts of money but they do condense a
lot of information in a short amount of
time of course boot camps nowadays have
things like delayed tuition agreements
and income share agreements so that you
don't have to pay anything until you get
a job but it still costs a pretty penny
and shortening the process by going
through a structured program can
definitely be helpful but it's in a way
that kind of like dominates your life
it's nearly impossible to be a part of
these programs and have a full-time job
at the same time so it just doesn't make
sense for a lot of people so resources
really are the reason why you choose one
path over the other and self-taught is
definitely the cheapest of the three but
it doesn't necessarily mean it's the
easiest because you have to put together
all of the curriculum and structure
yourself not to mention you have to
provide all the energy and ambition and
motivation behind it yourself too for
better or worse it's kind of like the
diy version of creating your own career
it's a non-trivial task to teach
yourself how to become a software
engineer and so there's a few things you
should know beforehand so yes building
your coding skills is like definitely
the main focus of teaching yourself how
to code seems straightforward right like
that's like the core part of it all and
i can go on and on about which tutorials
and resources are good for like every
single technology out there but that's
gonna take time so i'm just gonna leave
links to the ones that i've been
recommended in the description box down
below but surprisingly i've learned that
like learning how to code is actually
not the hardest part at all teaching
yourself how to code more than anything
is challenging because it requires a ton
of willpower and motivation
realistically i think this goes for like
teaching yourself anything so whether
that be teaching yourself how
cryptocurrency works or learning how to
build your own furniture or learning how
to pour a perfect latte when there's a
lot of skills to be learned for anything
it just takes time and perseverance and
for something as abstract as coding it
can be really hard to stay on that path
and be motivated and focused the whole
way through i would go so far as to say
like the one main factor that separates
like who becomes a software engineer and
who doesn't it's dedication you have to
stick with it and sometimes it's for a
really long time i think anyone can do
anything if they want it badly enough
and have enough resources i think the
key is that you have to you have to like
it it has to be like a little bit fun
it takes
way longer than you think
if you want
to self-teach yourself um you have to
really
really want it now it's really easy to
get engulfed and like completely
swallowed by the coding world altogether
what is the thing you want so badly like
you would live it breathe it eat it for
breakfast right well that's where
balance comes in because without it it's
a one-way ticket to burnout without even
starting a job i feel like time
management is really important that's
what the issue was because i never
solved time management
you know and so i didn't have time for
other things which is super important so
how do you actually motivate yourself to
code in a way that doesn't take too much
away from you that's like the million
dollar question well the one thing that
i heard emphasized across many of these
interviews is to develop curiosity it
makes the learning and practice just
like a lot easier when you're genuinely
interested in what's going on
having a
like very keen sense of curiosity
is super important i think if you're
gonna teach yourself you're gonna need
to be able to dive into stuff and like
try and rip it apart and understand how
it works
i feel like they soak up information in
a different way to where they're a
different type of curiosity so maybe you
found that curiosity or maybe you're
working on developing it once you've got
it like where are you supposed to direct
it especially as you start well coding
of course everyone emphasized the
importance of really knowing your coding
foundation so things like data
structures and algorithms regardless of
what technologies and frameworks you're
going to work within all of those really
do serve as the backbone to anything
coding related you're going to do so
you're really going to want to work on
your coding foundations and i know i
know data structures and algorithms can
be dry boring and hard but one way i've
come to think about data structures is
that it's really just about like how do
you organize and efficiently store your
data it's kind of like figuring out how
to best organize your closet and
learning what kinds of containers are
available
and algorithms is learning how to work
with and play around with that data
there's a ton of great resources online
about data structures and algorithms too
like on brilliant.org who is the sponsor
of today's video if you've heard me talk
about brilliant before you know that
it's an app and website built around the
principle of active problem solving
because really like i truly believe this
in order to learn something you can't
just like read it and watch it you have
to actually do it and engage with it
brilliant has recently upped their
interactivity level on their platform to
a whole new level and they're constantly
updating courses to make it more
interactive so yes brilliant has a
course on algorithm fundamentals that
makes it really easy to understand how
algorithms work you don't have to dig
through the weeds of coding syntax to
learn algorithms and you can just shift
around these blocks of pseudo code and
get immediate feedback on your results
it's a super good way to understand how
computer algorithms work and then once
you have that down the coding syntax
honestly becomes a little bit less
intimidating because you know what when
it comes to things like data structures
and algorithms you want to have a really
good true understanding of those things
you can't just like regurgitate or
memorize them because interviewers and
other people are going to know if you
don't really understand them so i think
that brilliance course is really good to
helping develop that true understanding
if you'd like to join me in a community
of 8 million learners and educators
today click the link in the description
box down below or visit brilliant.org
hellomyugo thank you so much to billy
for sponsoring and now let's get back to
the video so there is one big blind spot
that people have when becoming software
engineers and wow if there's like one
thing i could shout from the rooftops
about like becoming a software engineer
it's this one don't forget the soft
skills this is important regardless of
how you learn how to code but especially
so if you're self-taught and you don't
have a community of other people to work
with like it's just not enough to be
like pumping out thousands of lines of
code by yourself every day of course
producing results and the technical
aspect of the job is very important but
it can't be the full picture for you
being resourceful dealing with adversity
or confusion or stress or just
challenging times and then communicating
your thoughts clearly is such an
important part of the job some people
call them intangibles for interviewers
or future co-workers or like anybody
you're gonna work with it's an important
ingredient they're gonna look for to see
if you're a great problem solver which
remember is the core part of software
engineering the skills you develop as a
software engineer is actually very
valuable
not just the coding side but the
resourcefulness i don't think that
software engineering is just about
coding all the time it's more about
problem solving you have to think about
the best way for your use cases before
you start typing so if software
engineering really is about problem
solving then a lot of it is going to be
about learning what you don't know this
is a really tricky place to be in when
you're self-taught because there's no
one like there to guide you along the
way and show you your blind spots like
for one thing it can be hard to know
what steps to take in the learning
process no one is there to tell you what
to try next so on top of having to teach
yourself you also have to know what to
teach yourself and it's just a really
hard thing to navigate you definitely
have the resources and talents to teach
yourself whatever you need to learn but
knowing what you need to know is like a
whole different issue entirely so yes at
any given time your self education it's
hard to know where to go or like what to
do next you don't always have a way of
knowing what's important versus what's
not like usually there's like professors
and like teachers to tell you those
kinds of things that's why it's really
important to find a mentor or a
community to help you along the right
path not only can they be a figure to
lead you on your path as you build it
right before you but it's just like
another human being to work alongside
you can learn from their mistakes
because they're going to show you the
path that they were on and tell you what
they had wished they had adjusted for
their own journey you can also network
from this person and expand your circle
beyond theirs which is way better than
starting from scratch i would start with
the meetups i would go be around the
engineers to see how they talk see see
the environment that they're in and also
to ask them the questions you know
because in that environment like if you
came to me i would be able to tell you
hey all right you want to start with the
basics here so yeah seek them out
wherever you can meetups community
events like online or in person be nice
and ask all the questions you can think
of you can absorb everything they say
about starting your career path and
sticking to it and what to know along
the way prioritize mentorship early on i
think that mentorship you have to get it
by like putting yourself out there i
would recommend going to meetups
definitely recommend
finding people that come from a similar
background as you or who can empathize
with you
one thing that really helped me overcome
imposter syndrome was getting a good
mentor
he i think was
was really good at letting me know like
guiding me in like the right direction
like that's not the best practice why
don't you do this instead and so through
his like guidance after a few months of
kind of learning like what the team
style is i was like confidently writing
code that would regularly end up in our
code base
and i think that just really built my
confidence
the skill is to develop a network around
you where you can
um ask people for help and it's also a
really valuable way of getting a
community around you who
have experience and you know what it's
important to remember you can totally
teach yourself how to code through
online resources and tutorials and all
of that but nothing is as valuable as
like another human being who knows
what's going on they're kind of like the
human cliff notes to that massive pile
of information online so as you learn
more stuff and you're growing your
journey and you start getting maybe
interviews and stuff like that it can be
hard to stop comparing yourself to
others there will be people on your
journey who went to better schools or
like chose to go to school when you
chose not to there will be people lucky
enough to meet influential people and
companies that they work with or at when
you feel like you haven't even gotten
your first chance yet but you can't look
at these people as if they're just like
you there's like a million more factors
in play and you know what they're just
not you and you know what having a
non-traditional background does mean
that you're different from others
whether better or for worse as a result
the people that i interviewed had some
sort of inkling of imposter syndrome
because they came from non-traditional
backgrounds definitely imposter syndrome
i feel like oh it's so like jumping into
engineering it was pretty daunting
already but when you just went to like a
three-month course online and your peers
next to you have been learning
theoretical algorithms and discrete
combinatorics for four years it feels
intimidating if you go to self-taught
route and kind of also like if you just
go any route because i definitely feel
this too
you're gonna meet people who you feel
like had a better education than you and
you're also gonna feel like they just
know a lot more than you two first of
all that will not always be true if it
ever is i really think that like you
learn what you need to learn at the time
that you learn it and that's all that
matters people might be a bit ahead or a
bit behind you but they might use like
different tools like we're all just on
our own journeys it's totally normal to
feel like you're not legitimate
especially when you're looking at your
resume and like you're looking at your
schooling or your accolades or your past
experience or whatever like that but in
the real world let me tell you companies
are looking for people who can do the
job it matters a little bit but it
doesn't matter that much whether you
learned your skills at harvard or ucsd
or even tick tock some places it does
matter where you go to school because
there is some sort of like educational
bias that exists
in tech in america
in general and stuff but that's also
because we see people from like ivy
league schools is like better than us
but like that's that's not always the
case like just because you go to the
school doesn't mean that you're gonna
make a good engineer also just because
you didn't go to school doesn't mean
that you'll make a bad engineer anyways
if you have the talent and the knowledge
you're gonna get a job and people at
these companies know that that's why
there's an entire interview process for
this i thought that uh i wouldn't be
taken seriously if i didn't have a cs
degree which wasn't true i don't even
remember any job that i had that you
know during the hiring process they
asked about my degree
it was actually more likely that oh you
have a criminology degree that tell me
about that experience that sounds
interesting like what'd you learn it was
more of a that's interesting and novel
and not something we see every day and
also like you had to get a computer
science degree some people say that i
was like i don't think you need that man
like because you need like programming
is kind of different than this computer
science you know the way you do things
is totally different so so if you're
self-taught then your learning pace is
decided by you so you're like the only
person on this journey so like it just
doesn't make sense to compare yourself
to other people that's what always gets
me about like this imposter feeling all
the time more than anything it just
doesn't like make logical sense to
belong to a group of people who are just
all so different from each other i just
think you know our lives and careers are
like too complex for comparisons like
that like we're learning about how many
other ways there are to live through the
internet and yes you could compare
yourself but you could also celebrate
the fact that there are so many
different ways to live and there's so
many different kinds of people out there
everybody learns at their own pace and
like as long as you understand the
concepts and you understand what you're
actually learning then that should be
the only thing that matters
it's just better to
go at your own pace not to think about
other people's paths i think it makes it
a lot easier to get through that all of
these things add up to a problem of
belief that can really affect you it
sounds simple and cheesy but you gotta
believe in yourself no matter where you
are in your journey or your education if
you believe that you someday can become
a software engineer then that's the most
important thing there's people less
qualified than you doing what you want
to be doing
because they believed in themselves
after working in the industry for a few
years all these people realized one by
one that a cs degree really isn't
necessary for a job nowadays where you
learned how to code is just not as
crucial anymore like their education
section unless you're in a university or
something like that is gonna be at the
very bottom of the resume so it's just
it's just not as important as things
like skills or experience
what's crucial nowadays is simply you
and your abilities no matter how you
came about them and as the tech world
has a lot of these traditionally
educated engineers like me i will add i
really think that people from
non-traditional backgrounds with
different perspectives are what's going
to shake up the tech industry in a
really interesting way so as tech
companies are looking to hire for their
teams voices like yours are really
important for their mission in order to
make the best stuff those like unique
and diverse identities and perspectives
are gonna open so many doors and avenues
that like people had just not previously
considered because these products and
services that are built by companies are
likely aimed at a non-tech audience that
has a diverse set of skills and
backgrounds and perspectives and
identities so it really only makes sense
that the people building the thing
represents the people who are gonna use
it i just think you make a much better
product that way because people from
different backgrounds are gonna bring up
concerns and ideas that are relevant to
them their identity and their community
so i think that software engineers from
non-traditional backgrounds are exactly
what the tech industry is lacking and
needs especially now so if you're
watching this and thinking about
becoming a self-taught developer
then please consider all of the above
because wow we need you here these
people all did it despite their vastly
different backgrounds experiences and
skill sets and interests look to them as
your proof that it's possible it won't
be easy but if you really want it we'll
be waiting on the other side thank you
all so much for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this video thank you so much
to everybody that i interviewed for this
video all of their links are down in the
description box down below so check them
out this is a video that i've always
really wanted to make and so i'm really
glad that i can finally make it for you
if you're interested in more videos like
these then make sure to click subscribe
alright hope you all have a great day
and i'll see you in the next video bye